entre mai et juillet cette année près de
6000 personnes ont répondu à un
questionnaire très ciblée souffrez vous
de tous ou problèmes respiratoires de
conjonctivites ou de malaise de
migraines ou de nausées
à cette période notre littoral était
fortement impacté par l'arrivage massive
d'algues sargasses et les émanations
permanente
l'ammoniaque et d'hydrogène sulfuré
provoqué dans la population une profonde
détresse
on a eu beaucoup de commentaires en fait
sur la souffrance
les gens qui ressentent l odeur de
manière permanente qui avait beaucoup de
symptômes au niveau digestif au niveau
neurologique
après il y avait aussi des symptômes orl
ou pulmonaires il y avait des
commentaires qui était très marquant
avec des gens qui nous suppliaient de
faire quelque chose parce qu'il se
sentait vraiment abandonné et qu'il
savait pas quoi faire l'étude est
d'autant plus essentielle quelle est la
première à questionner la population sur
les effets chroniques de l'intoxication
en martinique comme en guadeloupe les
symptômes les plus fréquents sont les
problèmes digestifs
les trois quarts des personnes
interrogées souffre de vomissements
douleurs abdominales
viennent ensuite les symptômes
neurologiques six personnes sur dix
ressentent maux de tête vertiges et
malaise et tous ces symptômes sont
d'autant plus sérieux en fonction de la
proximité du littoral dans un proche
avenir les médecins libéraux veulent
suivre une population volontaire dans
une commune pour étudier l'évolution des
symptômes sur trois à cinq ans là on va
voir un médecin qui va les examiner
qui va poser un certain nombre de
questions et les personnes vont répondre
à ce questionnaire tous les trois mois
tous les six mois et ça pendant une
durée
donc c'est une étude prospective avec
l'accord des patients mais cela ce avec
un recueil de données fait par un
médecin pour voir dans le long terme
enfin plutôt plutôt moins dans le moyen
terme si les symptômes durent et sont
les mêmes ou si on a d'autres symptômes
qui apparaissent d'éventuelles
conséquences à venir dont nous ignorons
tout pour l'instant la ville du robert
est d'ores et déjà volontaires dans
cette démarche